- When these music requests
come in for Rick and Morty,
I never know what to expect.
- I, I, I need to know what a
frog planet's instruments
would sound like.
It's like an intergalactic race
riot, but it's a love story.
I need a royal march for an insect species
that thinks it's koalas.
- I write all the music
for Rick and Morty.
In fact, my name's in
the credits, hold on.
(electronic music)
(bell chimes)
(otherworldly music)
(soft electronic music)
Take for example in
season one, episode two,
I had to score this alien
bondage dream sequence.
It took awhile to figure
it out, but once I realized
I could use this Gregorian
chant as a background element,
really came together.
(camera shutter clicks)
So you know the episode Get
Schwifty, that alien band
that gets annihilated.
I had to make it sound like
they were playing instruments
from another planet using
only instruments from Earth.
So I used a bunch of
percussion instruments
from all over the world.
My favorite song I
wrote for Rick and Morty
was Goodbye Moon Men, which is
kind of a David Bowie thing,
and actually, if you listen
close, you can hear me
singing background vocals.
Here, I'll prove it.
♫ Goodbye moon men
♫ You say goodbye moon men
♫ Goodbye
♫ Moon men
I left a couple of musical
Easter eggs in the show,
and I'll tell you about one of them.
In season one, I wrote a
song called Human Music,
and you can hear it in
season two in the lobby of
Jerry Daycare.
(metal cranking)
Not everything's purposeful, though.
The theme song I actually
wrote for another show
that didn't get picked up,
we used it as temporary
music for Rick and Morty,
and everyone liked it so
we just decided to keep it.
So I've been with Rick and
Morty since before the beginning,
and I've seen all sorts
of music requests come in.
And sometimes it gets a
little weird, but, you know,
I like weird, and I wouldn't
have it any other way.
- Ryan, I really wanna
do a rap about the flu,
and can you do it this tempo?
(beat boxing)
Whatever that tempo is,
but give me five versions.